[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's seth wickersham espn senior writer
and he's got a new book out it's better
to be feared the new england patriots
dynasty in the pursuit of greatness
seth thanks for joining us what was the
toughest story in all of this to crack
oh man that's a great question thanks
for having me i think that
the toughest story and this made sound a
little bit more thematic than specific
but it's trying to get inside
how bill belichick and tom brady work on
a day-to-day basis and try to diagnose
and understand the key ingredients that
have led to their greatness and this
unprecedented run that they had together
and then also look at some of the costs
of that greatness i think that those
were the things that i was trying to
pursue as diligently as i possibly could
easier to get information on brady or
belichick
um
that's a great question
i'd say it's a it's a it's about the
same i mean i wouldn't say it's easy but
you know again i've been doing this for
20 years now i've written many stories
about tom brady i've been at his house
i've been in a super bowl party i've had
many conversations with bill belichick i
know the people around them i know the
coaches on the staff and so i just felt
like that i could pursue this project
with a lot of confidence and hopefully
tell a story that fans like what's the
one that you
the story that you found out more
information than previously uh believed
or reported
oh man i mean there's a lot of those
things
you know you can go back to
you know tom brady's days in michigan
and the night that he was going to leave
and what his therapist and counselor
told him
um you know the tension of 2017 which i
obviously wrote a lot about the time and
you know just learning a little bit more
about
you know where that came from how bad
things got you know how brady said i
don't want to play for bill anymore and
you know how close it came to coming to
an end there
and um you know the part of the book in
a weird way that i like the best or that
i kind of enjoy the most was
the middle part the 10 years that they
didn't win a championship because
they were
achieving at such a high level and they
were in such a
cultural and
you know
sports plateau
but
they needed to figure out how to how to
get the last percentage of a percentage
um better so that they could you know go
over the hump and and finally win more
super bowls rather than narrowly losing
them to the new york giants
and you've said that you didn't
interview brady or belichick for this
book but you have interviewed them down
through the years i give you one
question for both of them let me start
with belichick the one question you
would ask
for this book would have been what
i think i would have asked if it's all
worth it i think that he's become the
greatest coach in modern football
history
and the casualty of his greatness has
been a lot of relationships you know you
can talk about his relationship with
eric mangini and how that fell apart
when eric left and i detail a near-fist
fight at the league meetings between the
two of them
and there's a lot of players over the
years who obviously have come out of new
england
um with a really bad taste in their
mouth and then obviously there's tom
brady and i think that while there's a
lot of love between brady and belichick
i think that there's
a lot of acrimony especially on the
brady side at the way that the past
couple years you know unfolded and you
know that's what i would be curious how
he would answer um is
you know
if those relationships are some of the
costs of his greatness how does he feel
about it and was it all worth it what
would be the question you would ask
brady you know i thought about this a
lot but i actually did ask it to him a
couple years ago and i asked him how
long he wanted to live
because if you look at the way that he's
sort of evolved in celebrity no he's
become
this this kind of figure that he's
almost a member of like the global elite
for whom you know human longevity is
human destiny and so i did ask him at
one point like how long do you want to
live
and he had a really thoughtful and um
and and you know reasonable answer where
he said you know it's not necessarily
about
how long i want to live even though he
wrote an entire book about reversing the
aging process in his words it was the
quality of life and the fact that he
wanted to go skiing and surf and do
these things after football and he was
trying to have it all and we'll see if
he can have it all yeah but if i ask you
how long do you want to live seth
what are you going to say
well i didn't write an entire book about
reversing i know but i if i'm tom it's
like i want quality of life however long
i live i want quality of life um
i i've always been fascinated with a
couple of stories the was there a power
struggle on keeping jimmy garoppolo
keeping tom who had the final say did
did brady go to kraft and say it's me or
him belichick hand delivered jimmy
garoppolo to kyle shanahan making sure
he didn't go to the cleveland browns
help me understand all of that
illuminate me on you know what is fact
what's fiction it takes a little bit of
time but and i wrote about this a lot at
the time look after they beat the
falcons and they had won their fifth
super bowl the dynamics in the building
just changed and i think that you know
tom brady started to venture into other
things his tb-12 business he put out the
book he did time versus time he wanted
to be treated a little bit differently
and
in the middle of it all you had alex
guerrero in this business that they were
both trying to build together and the
fact that the things that they were
saying were often at odds with what the
patriots doctors were saying and so it
was becoming this divisive force in the
locker room
belichick curtailed his access i mean
think about the tampa bay buccaneers
right now they give alex guerrero an
office and they gave him a super bowl
ring bill curtailed his access back then
and in the middle of it all you had
jimmy garoppolo and the fact that
belichick
has a lot of pride and he always wanted
to walk away from the patriots with them
set up long term at quarterback and he
was deeply invested in jimmy at one
point when jimmy played he said you know
the transition between brady and jimmy
is really seamless seamless
on offense
and
things were there was just a lot of
things coming to a head and so finally
jimmy got shipped it was obvious that
kraft's loyalties were to brady
and um
then that off season they lose to the
philadelphia eagles and brady skips the
entire offseason program and so much
reporting has come out about how he
really didn't know if he wanted to
return to the team and in fact kind of
wanted to be released
okay but did he go to craft and say it's
either me or garoppolo
well i that i don't know but kraft
tom brady didn't get jimmy garoppolo
traded i think that it was so obvious
that craft had stated publicly and
privately that brady had earned the
right to walk away on his own terms and
even if bill was invested in jimmy tom
was making it very hard for him to get
on the field they shared an agent don
yee there was just a lot of things that
were closing in and bill was kind of
backed into a corner and so yes he calls
up kyle shanahan i think it was on
halloween morning maybe the night the
day before
and offers jimmy you know straight up
for a second round pick
belichick has since come out and said
when he's
the book has been mentioned that uh you
know second third fourth hand
news
it feels like
information may be coming from brady's
side more than belichick's side that
probably doesn't take long to go through
the rolodex of belichick and who he
trusts and who would have information
here is that a fair assessment on how
i'm reading who's saying what to whom
and when and why
it's a fair assessment of
i think what came out in the news story
but most of the the book is is not that
way i mean 95 of the people that i
talked to for the book are on the record
and their primary sources and the the
few that i needed to grant anonymity to
are the people who had first-hand
um knowledge of key meetings or
dialogue that was said and so
um i think with the newser it definitely
some of the news that came out
definitely came out that way
but
you know specifically with the
the main anecdote from the new story
about tom brady and at robert craft's
house and and telling robert craft he's
not going to resign with the team
he wanted to go tell bill in person and
bill was unavailable and you know he
told a confidant a very close friend he
thought that was telling of the state of
their relationship you know brady didn't
deny that yesterday i mean tom is 44
years old and he's good he figured out a
way to thread that needle where he
didn't deny it and he didn't really give
away anything away either and um
you know like i said i i did the best i
could to try to show this relationship
show their greatness and show the cost
of their greatness we're talking to seth
wickersham espn senior writer author the
book is available nationally on tuesday
it's better to be feared the new england
patriots dynasty and the pursuit of
greatness i've mentioned this story to
my audience a couple of times when i
interviewed brady prior to the super
bowl with the eagles
and towards the end i said
do you think you and bill will ever get
together and reminisce
and brady in a moment of truth
said
no like he he couldn't believe that i
was
asking that almost like incred like no
are you kidding me that that's that's
not what our relation now he didn't say
that's not what our relationship was
about but that's really how i read it
he's like no
and and i i don't know if he caught
himself where he gave me what i thought
was an honest answer at the time instead
of saying well i hope so and you know we
will open up the scrapbook and you know
we have so many great memories he just
went
no
would you say that sums up the
relationship between these two that
they're not taking a trip down memory
lane anytime soon
not anytime soon but i still think that
even if they
get on each other's nerves and there's
some acrimony i think especially on the
brady side right now over how things
ended in new england the past few years
but i i think that there's a love there
and i think that that's really important
and
you know as different as they are from a
personality standpoint they have a
couple key traits that are almost
completely aligned and i think that one
of them
they are steadfast optimists they kind
of come in it from a different angle but
nobody in nfl history has believed in
the power and the possibilities of the
next play like these guys i mean no
matter what has happened they're able to
focus on what's in front of them and you
see it play out on these international
stages where brady rallies the team from
28 to 3 down and a year before another
brilliant goal line stand by a belichick
defense i mean nobody like these two
guys
they refuse to concede an inch to
anybody else's idea of the inevitable i
wonder if they get blown out
42 to 10 by the falcons
does bill move on from brady sooner
yeah that's a great question um
i think there's a strong likelihood one
of the things i i get into in the book
is
i think that one of the things that
reignited their dynasty was in the
baltimore divisional playoff game in
2015 when they were down 14 points in
the third quarter and they unveiled that
the baltimore and the ravens funky
formations that completely baffled the
ravens and it got new england back in
this game
and if they had lost that game i don't
know what would have happened i mean
jimmy garoppolo had just finished his
rookie season would they have moved on
from brady right then but instead they
unveiled this this classic formation
that completely befuddled the ravens got
them back in the game and it really
reignited the entire dynasty and led to
those three more super bowls you want to
get in on the uh pre-game bet is there a
hug
is there a handshake is there any
contact whatsoever between brady and
belichick
so i would bet and i'm not a better but
i would bet that there will be a pregame
hug because there'll be too many cameras
after the game
and i think they'll both do it because
they know that it's in their best
interest to do it and i often wonder you
know look i mean brady's going to be so
focused and so keyed up for this game
whether they will try to show him so
much love at that stadium like a video
tribute whatever to kind of throw him
off oh i would absolutely seth i would i
would make him cry
the colts did it with peyton manning
when he came back as a denver bronco
they did this big tribute to him and he
started crying during pregame warm-ups
and so like i absolutely think that's
the best way to try to throw brady off
great to talk to you seth congrats on
the book and good luck with the sales
thanks man i'll talk to you that's seth
wickersham the book it's better to be
feared the new england patriots dynasty
the pursuit of greatness released
nationally
uh on tuesday october 12th